[Musique]
le 24 avril 1915 commençait le prier du
20e siècle organisé par le gouvernement
des Jeunes
Turcs plus d'un million et demi
d'Arméniens 500000 assyos caldéens
syriques ont été tués parce qu'ils
étaient
chrétiens assassinés dans leur village
exécutés ou laissé agonisant de soif et
d'épuisement dans les déserts sur la
route de
derersor ils ont été canonisés comme
martyr de la foi en
[Musique]
2015 ceux qui ont pu survivre ceux qui
ont vu la mort de leurs proches ont été
exilés de leur terre natale à la
recherche d'une terre d'asile en passant
par la Syrie le Liban ou la Grèce plus
de 100000 rescapés sont arrivés à
Marseille dans les années
20 pour ces Arméniens apostoliques
catholiques et évangéliques une nouvelle
vie
commençait
chez Aram et bien on peut reconstituer
le parcours d'un réfugié arménien depuis
malheureusement son exode à travers les
déserts syriens il il a pu se retrouver
dans un camp à Halep il a pu passer
également en transit à Beyrouth et on a
également la possibilité de voir dès son
arrivée au débarquement de Marseille
toutes les vicissitudes administratives
qu'il a pu traverser ici on a une pièce
tout à fait
intéressante c'est un passeport d'une
famille une partie écrite en arménien
une partie en français et c'est un
passeport vous le voyez collectif donc
on voit la famille avec les enfants un
autre passeport c'est assez émouvant
c'est celui de mon grand-père SAAC
artine et on voit déjà l'erreur
administrative il s'appelait sahac
queant fils de Artin que c'estan il est
passé par Bagdad et qui était sous
protectorat anglais et là on voit
véritablement que l'officier d'état
civil s'est trompé et en fait a écrit
Sahak son fartin et le cant a disparu
donc on voit également il est avec son
épouse ici et au revers également et là
pareil nous voyons tout ce parcours où
il a pu passer par le port de berou vu à
l'embarquement et il arrive en 192 4 à
[Musique]
Marseille pourquoi sont-ils arrivés en
France tout d'abord parce qu'il
cherchait les terres d'accueil et
surtout parce que la France avait un
besoin immense de bras travailleur vous
savez très bien qu'elle avait été
saignée à blanc avec 1500000 bords
durant la Première Guerre mondiale al
bien sûr ils sont arrivés en bateau il y
avait à Marseille une petite communauté
arménienne installée ici à partir du
milieu du 19e siècle et un peu plus
étaufé après l'ouverture du canal de
Suède une communauté structurée avec sa
chapelle ses structures communautaires
et ce sont eux qui ont tendu la première
main secourable à ses
[Rires]
[Musique]
rescapé quand un Arménien arrive à
Marseille le gouvernement turc lui a ôté
cette nationalité et donc il se retrouve
à patride la plupart des passeports ont
une indication souvent ne peut pas
retourner ou sans retour possible c'est
un parcours tout de même très très
difficile pour ces réfugiés et ensuite
et bien ils vont être pris en char par
des
associations ils les ont installés dans
les petits hôtels du centre-eville leur
donnant aussi un petit viatique pour
vivre jusqu'à ce qu'ils retrouve leurs
esprits mais si les premières semaines
c'était quelques dizaines ou quelques
centaines qui arrivai à partir de 23 ça
a été le déferement par millier et il y
a eu une large part de de l'opinion
publique Marseillaise et de la presse
qui leur a été favorable mais
malheureusement
nous avons eu un maire à l'époque qui
s'appelait le docteur flessière radical
socialiste sénateur maire qui a écrit
une lettre au préfet une lettre immonde
dont l'actuel maire Monsieur Godin
disait que c'était une honte pour
Marseille Monsieur le Préfet on annonce
que 40000 Arméniens sont en route pour
la France ce qui revient à dire que la
variole le tifus et la peste se dirigent
vers nous peut-être sont-ils déjà en
germe pululant depuis l'arrivée des
premiers de ces immigrants dénués de
tout réfractaires à nos meurces
occidentales Rebell à toute mesure
d'hygiène immobilisé dans leur indolence
résignée passive
[Musique]
ancestrale la population marseillaise
réclame du gouvernement qu'il interdise
rigoureusement l'entrée des ports
français à ses immigrants et qu'il
rapatrie sans délais ces lamentables
troupeaux humains gros danger public
pour le pays tout
entier monsieur dikram moyans qui était
consul d'Arménie à Marseille c'est
adressé au préfet qui a mis à la
disposition des réfugiés le fameux camp
ODS alors le camp est ouvert donc le 27
novembre 22 c'est un ancien camp
militaire donc en prenant l'exemple de
mon grand-père il est arrivé en
septembre donc 24 et vous le voyez ici
donc il matricule
4774 on reconnaît donc son degré de
parenté c'est le chef de famille il a
son âge son lieu de naissance siivas
bien sûr s'il est marié ou pas le Codo a
été un exemple d'autogestion durant les
3 années de son existence jusqu'à
1926 si l'on lit le rapport d'activité
du comité de gestion on demeure
[Musique]
ébahi
ce caondo qui a été démantelé par la
suite comporta 34 bâtiments en bois que
les Arméniens ont eux-mêmes rénovés
aménagé cloisonné c'était des familles
qui habitaient là il y avait un bâtiment
qui servait le dimanche de lieu de culte
et des réfugiés bon qui avaient tous
reçu une éducation chrétienne dans le
pays bien euh était à dans une immense
majorité euh très lié à leur église à
leur identité aussi bien nationale
culturelle que religieuse ils se sont
d'abord organisés autour d'une vie
religieuse dès le camp AUO c'est comme
ça qu'ils se sont mis en place
progressivement la première chose qu'ils
ont construite c'est les églises
arméniennes sur Marseille ils ont
commencé très tôt ils avaient pensé dans
le camp ils ont continué ensuite a y
pensé dans les quartiers où ils se sont
retrouvés comme ici à
saint-gérome il y avait un homme
Monseigneur kcores balquan qui a bien
compris que ce qui était important pour
cette communauté diasporique qui est en
train de se créer sur le sol français et
en tous les cas à Marseille ce qui était
important c'était c'était la ferveur
religieuse et de garder cette identité
cultuelle et
culturelle
[Musique]
Co
ankoaz
it amen Monseigneur kekoris Balagan il
s'est dit que le lieu de rassemblement
c'était les églises et partout
progressivement la communauté arméenne
s'est s'est retrouvé en quittant le
campodo de partout il a mis en place les
églises et notamment ici à Saint-Jérome
alors ce qu'on voit derrière c'est bien
ça c'est les noms des grands et
principaux donateurs de l'église de
l'église de saint-gérôme c'est ceux qui
ont permis de de réaliser l'édifice dans
lequel on est on est aujourd'hui
Monseigneur Balakian il a été le pasteur
qui a réellement donné courage à ces
brebis complètement égarés d'ailleurs je
dirais qu'il vaut la peine de lire ces
lettres pastorales qui sont d'une
élévation de pensée inouï mon peuple
arménien exilé toi aussi par rang
clairsemé tu es venu sous ces étoiles
étrangères gardant en ton cœur le deuil
éternel de tes êtres chers tombés sans
sépulture dans les vallées de ta
patrie mais plus que le présent c'est le
souci du lendemain qui angoisse ton âme
tourmentée jusqu'à quand vas-tu ainsi
vivre sans toi errant et sans
[Musique]
défense on voit tout simplement tous les
trajets de nouveau de ces réfugiés qui
vont partir soit à Paris soit au Brésil
pour certains soit dans le tarnégaron
dans des industries de la valée
rodanienne et donc dans ce camp il va y
trouver une école il va y trouver une
chapelle il va y trouver également la
possibilité de retrouver des gens de des
associations compatriotiques et ces
associations compatriotiques les ont
aidé aussi à se regrouper dans divers
quartiers de Marseille lorsque après la
fermeture du coudo en 1926 il y a eu cet
exode encouragé d'ailleurs par
monsigneur
Balakian d'aller vers la banlieue un peu
plus saine parce que c'est ces hôtel mux
était très malsin les Arméniens ont été
heureux de retrouver un lopin de terre
qui leur rappelait un peu leur jardin de
lavas construire une petite maison un
toit à eux planter de petits arbres
fruits Ruti faire pousser la tomate ou
les concombres c'était quelque chose qui
leur rappelait aussi le
pays puisque nous vivons à l'étranger
tendez-vous une main fraternelle allégez
vos fardeaux etessuyez vos larmes
réciproquement car vous êtes tous des
compagnons de
souffrance vous le savez les compagnons
de chagrin qui ont partager le même sort
ne s'oublie jamais l'unité est la mère
de tous les bienfaits des unions le
parent de tous les
mots les premiers Arméniens arrivés ici
étaient des Arméniens originaires de la
siliciie notamment d'Adana et des villes
de Marach d'ailleurs vous avez le bar
ici qui est à côté qui s'appelle bar
silici et qui a été donc créé fondé ici
euh au début des années 20 et et qui
existe toujours bonjour bonjour bonjour
ch Marco ça va ou
oui très
bienessir voilà donc c'est là que son
retrouvai tous les tous les anciens
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés ici et ce bar
était un bar particulièrement vivant et
bien sûr maintenant nous avons changé de
génération hein
et les jeunes également sont allés un
petit peu aux alentours et il y a un peu
moins de de d'arméens ou de famillees
arméniennes qui habit à Saint-Loup mais
tout de même ça reste un quartier
particulièrement marqué par sont passé
et ce passé a été toujours marqué par
l'Église la première chose que les
Arméniens ont fait ici c'est de
construire leur église avant de
construire leur propre maison et très
souvent les anciens nous disaient que
parfois ils prenaient des matériaux de
leur maison et venaient pour construire
l'église donc il y a eu ce lien intime
entre le peuple et son
église
[Musique]
il y avait une ambiance extrêmement
familiale et conviviale les portes
n'étaient jamais fermées on pouvait
rentrer d'une maison à l'autre donc il y
avait une amitié une convivialité et
surtout un partage une solidarité entre
les gens notamment à des moments parfois
difficiles et compliqués pour les uns et
pour les
autres
[Musique]
voyez ici c'est la maison de mes parents
qui date donc de 1927 28 bien dans cette
rue c'est c'était des maisons qui se
construisaient au fur et à mesure que
les Arméniens venaient s'emplanter
jusqu' aux années 30 35 euh le quartier
donc a été définitivement je disais je
dirais constitué et le dimanche toute la
journée le quartier était inondé de
champ et de musique
arménienne au cours de cette courte
période succédant à cet horrible martyre
tu es déjà debout afin de mener le
combat pour ta vie individuelle et
collective et ainsi donner le témoignage
éclatant de tes efforts
[Musique]
assidus oui ce jour est le jour de ta
victoire morale puisque'au cours des
trois dernières années tu as déjà édifié
h églises et fondé 12
écoles Monseigneur
Balakian lorsqu'il a bâti ses églises il
s'est mué en maçon il a plié sa soutane
il a Charié sur ses épaules les pierres
les briques le ciment il a doté chaque
église d'une école comme le dit un
dicton arménien là où TR Arméniens une
église là où une église une école voilà
c'est le fondement de ce
raisonnement il fallait bien sûr ici
aussi avoir des écoles pour péréniser
notre culture notre foi nots tradition
et notre langue il a doté chaque
quartier d'une section de secours
mutuel non seulement il a battu des
églises mais il a battu des
âmes
pour faire ça il était habité du
Saint-Esprit il a pasautre
explication
[Musique]
nous sommes ici à l'église
saintgalabette le
précurseur première église arménienne
consacré par Monseigneur Balak en
décembre
1928 ici vous avez un panorama
magnifique sur l'arade et le port de
Marseille et les Arméniens à partir de
1926-27 sont venus construire ici leur
premier
[Musique]
village si l'on prend la carte de
Marseille les Arméniens se sont
installés surtout dans ce qu'on appelle
maintenant les quartiers nords
le 15e arrondissement de Marseille
renferme trois lieux de culte
orthodoxe la paroisse Saint-Jacques où
nous sommes saint garabette à campagne
fraise et saintateos partorios de
l'autre côté aussi une petite église
protestante ils sont installés aussi à
saint-gérob à beaont à
saint-lou ils sont installés à N dans
des quartiers ils ont eux-mêmes fondés
ou bâtis et qui se trouvaient pour la
plupart loin des moyens de transport de
l'époque qui était le tranou parce que
les terrains étaient bon marché et qu'on
construisait facilement une petite
maison de de trois
pièces saint-gérême c'est la compampagne
faut l'imaginer et on a une famille la
famille poméon qui dispose du cette
immense campagne qui va tout simplement
simplement parcéisé et finalement dans
ce contexte favorable au niveau du
travail et à la fois de l'immobilier un
noyau arménien va se faire vous avez une
solidaritéin on a des corps de métier on
fait appel au voisins qui sait faire
donc maçon l'autre qui peut travailler
la charpente en bois je rappelle que la
maison arménienne c'est une maison
évolutive selon le nombre d'enfants et
selon les moyens une maison à un et plus
tard deux niveaux on a donc dans ce
quartier
de saint-gérôme bien sûr la paroisse
sous l'impulsion de Monseigneur balquon
donc cette chapelle elle va être
construite et la première messe va avoir
lieu donc en 32 donc ici on dispose d'un
plan des parcelles c'est le plan
cadastral des parcelle sur le domaine de
la campagne poméon à Saint-Jérôme en
1927 on reconnaît laavenue de
Saint-Jérôme on reconnaît également le
boulevard donc
hararat
le boulevard
casoran et le boulevard plus tard qui
s'appellera Charles et tountian où il y
a la paroisse de
[Musique]
Saint-Jérôme auberg
far une courgette et une
tomate il va avoir des Arméniens qui
vont être bien sûr commerçants parce
qu'il faut aussi retrouver peut-être le
goût des des terres que l'on a
[Musique]
quitté c'est une Petite Arménie en effet
beaucoup d'Arméniens n'avaient pas
besoin de parler français finalement
l'épiciier était arménien le boucher
était arménien également le médecin qui
était arménien donc finalement c'est un
noyau villageois
important pour cette communauté
arménienne elle va retrouver ses repères
qu'elle avait
[Musique]
perdu les Arméniens étaient des artisans
surtout et des commerçants don le cuir
l'habillement les méteaux
et ce sont sur les bases de ces métiers
là que les Arméniens ont prospéré ici
[Musique]
aussi00 de00
de par exemple ils ont fait de Marseille
le 4e centre de production de chaussures
de France après roman fougère et moulin
ici par exemple vous avez le premier
atelier la famille capelagan et voilà
donc des familles qui
vont travailler le cuir de père en fils
vous allez avoir donc beaucoup de
travaux on va dire comme manœuvre donc
vous allez avoir une usine l'usine coder
vous allez avoir les huileries les
savonneries le travail est difficile on
doit faire les 3 h il n'est pas besoin
c'est vrai de parler français mais le
travail est difficile on côtoie les
Italiens également qui sont là et on a
pas mal d'arméniia également chez les
dockers voilà donc des travaux qui ne
sont pas
véritablement intellectuel et on a
également un travail où au contraire il
faut avoir un savoir-faire et ce
savoir-faire ce sont des femmes qui le
détiennent des femmes d'une région de
Césaré et elles vont être recrutées
souvent dès leur arrivé et elles vont
s'installer dans le quartier de
Saint-Jérôme parce que nous avons ici
une fabrique la fabrique France Orient
qui fabrique des tapis des tapis avec
des nœuds très précis et je vous laisse
ici découvrir par
exemple donc la maquette du dessin qui
reprend donc les couleurs et également
donc toute la géométrie que l'on va
retrouver sur des tapis dit pour
certains perçant ou dit de taabis ils
sont aussi adaptés au métier moderne en
devenant mécanicien électricien et
cetera parce que Marseille jusque dans
les années 1960 70 a été une grande
ville
industrielle aujourd'hui grâce à cette
large hospitalité qui nous a été offerte
et grâce bien sûr à notre labeur nous
avons bâti nos petites
maisons nous avons rempli les rues de
nos quartiers de milliers d'enfants
alert et Gaillard gage de notre avenir
aussi est-ce pour cela que si nous
brûlons parfois nous ne serons jamais
réduits en
cendre quand ces réfugiés sont arrivés
le premier sentiment qu'ils avaient
c'est un sentiment de reconnaissance
bien sûr d'être accueilli l'évêque leur
disait
d'être loyal envers la France qui les
accueiller de ne pas aller contre ces
lois d'être les citoyens fidèle mais de
ne pas oublier aussi leurs origines et
ce qu'ils étaient donc il est plein de
reconnaissance envers la France
lorsqu'on lit ses lettres pastorales
monur balqu la noble France fidèle à ses
traditions séculaires d'humanisme a
accueilli les nôtres par milliers alors
que bien d'autres pays nous ont fermé
leurs portes n'oublie pas cet
hospitalité apprend convenablement sa
belle langue c'est l'occasion
d'assimiler sa magnifique culture aime
la France en te rappelant qu'elle est la
patrie des grands idéaux
humanistes un réfugié arménien a mis les
pieds ENF a débarqué sur les pied de la
Joliette une trentaine de milliers sont
restés à Marseille et dans les
environs l'immense majorité a suivi le
filon de la vallée Duron à partir
d'Avignon montellimar Valence qui est
devenue la la ville la plus arménienne
de France si on peut dire
en rapport de la population totale la
région lonaise le creusau et la région
parisienne et il y a à peu près 25 30000
personnes qui sont passées en transit de
France pour prendre les bateaux au Havre
et à Bordeaux vers les Amériques du Nord
et du
Sud
salut vous êtes en forme ça bien on a du
boulot toi très
bien poursuit voilà donc nous sommes en
présence d'une photo historique datant
donc des années
181 les survivants des volontaires
arménien de France sous les drapeaux
français engagés donc dans la première
guerre mondiale alors où on parle
actuellement de la résilience je trouve
que tous ces réfugiés arméniens ont
véritablement qu'ils étaient dans la
résilience ils ont vu l'horreur ils ont
vu l'indicible et là ils se sont
reconstruits et ils nous ont pas élevés
dans la haine et au contraire dans la
mémoire et dans l'amour donc je pense
que ces Arméniens qui sont venus ici et
bien ce qu'il ce qu'ils voulaient c'est
surtout nous laisser cette mémoire
comment après un traumatisme tel de
génocide cette communauté arménienne à
Marseille à Lyon à Paris elle a pu se
reconstruire grâce à quoi sur quelle
fondation et je pense que c'est tout ce
travail que l'on essaie de trouver voilà
quelles sont les fondations de la
communauté arménien en
France il a été refait par genou et par
ça a été
réparé par l'atelier par l'atelier
d'accord ce que moi je ne vis pas bien
c'est c'est le fait de pas pouvoir
accompagner mon fils quand il fait un
arbre généalogique parce qu'on arrive
pas on peut pas remonter on peut pas
remonter au-delà de nos arrières
grands-parents donc les les parents de
de nos parents et là on se sent un peu
désarmé on se dit mais et notre culture
elle a plus de 3000 ans et en même temps
quand on demande des preuves tangibles
ne soit-ce que des noms et une une
généalogie on est incapable de la donner
et là on se sent complètement
désarmé nos anciens voulaient nous
épargner ils m'ont transmis que en ayant
vécu l'horreur ils sont ils ont été
capables de nous distribuer le bonheur
parce que leur souci premier était que
nous allions à l'école que nous nous
intégrions au pays et donc ils ont
intériorisé leur souffrance pour nous
[Musique]
épargner
l'intérêt de travailler ici c'est de
préserver la mémoire de la
transmettre et surtout de faire en sorte
que les générations qui viennent ne
n'oubli pas donc entretenir la mémoire
pour rentrer dans l'histoire de manière
ce que ce soit une mémoire
[Musique]
vivante
uni
Karun
[Musique]
yerküelne im
Hane